bonsoir alexis merci d'être avec nous
plus de 50000 adhésion en septembre ça
donc plutôt bien marché cette opération
ce qu'on peut parler d'un engouement
engouement populaire où on s'emballe un
peu
s'emballe un peu je crois alors certes
ça a bien marché 50000 adhésion pour
cinq candidats ça fait dix mille par
candidat on voit que chaque camp a
essayé de recruter un maximum que ce
soit en savoie pour michel barnier en
paca pour eric ciotti en ile-de-france
où il ya beaucoup également d'adhésion
pour valérie pécresse et puis dans le
nord évidemment avec xavier bertrand là
on voit que tout le monde essaye de
récupérer notamment xavier bertrand et
valérie pécresse qui avait quitté le
parti et qui essaye de séduire de
nouveaux arrivants qui vont voter parce
que chaque voix qui est maintenant
comptabilisé ceux qui payent pour voter
vont forcément voté et ont déjà choisi
finalement leur champion ou leur
championne donc c'est extrêmement
important évidemment de savoir
engouement populaire on en est loin on
est loin bien sûr des 4 millions qui ont
voté à la primaire en 2017 pour françois
fillon donc là on est vraiment sur des
échelles qui ne sont pas les mêmes à tel
point que certains leaders de la droite
un critique et la cgt en disant qu'elle
n'avait aucun poids alors que la cgt à
600 mille adhérents là on est à 100 150
mille adhérents voyez que c'est loin des
chiffres passés pour les grands partis
alexis est ce qu'on sait déjà qui peut
profiter cette à cet engouement vous
m'avez corriger mais voilà cet
enthousiasme on va dire
ben c'est enthousiasmant oui il est des
gens qui veulent voter on a des
sympathisants de droite des électeurs de
droite qui veulent un champion une
championne de la droite qui veulent
quelqu'un qui va les représenter à cette
élection parce que on voit bien que ça
tire dans tous les côtés entre émane de
mâcon qui tire le tapis eric zemmour qui
arrive comme un chien dans un jeu de
quilles là pour ces nouveaux arrivants
ça va sans doute favoriser quelqu'un
comme xavier bertrand ou valérie
pécresse qui avait quitté le parti et
qu'il se défend d'avoir voulu faire
autre chose qui dise voilà maintenant il
faut réunir la famille de droite ce que
fait d'ailleurs la droite et ce qui a du
mal à faire la gauche puisque
c'est l'hécatombe a disons que les les
scores dans les sondages des différents
candidats restent assez faibles et
certains voudraient faire l'union la
droite au moins la consigne est claire
faisons une union autour d'un candidat
d'une candidate mais avec un débat
d'idées sens a aucune chance de se
retrouver au second tour alors encore de
débats pour départager les candidats que
retenir des deux premières réunions
thématiques de l air une appartient en
recherche d'un leader peut-être pas
clairement oui et on voit que ils ont du
mal à se démarquer les uns des autres
puisque il faut rassurer les électeurs
de droite et dire que cette fois ci les
républicains la droite républicaine
revient dans le jeu politique en force
parce que c'est un parti qui a du mal à
être dans l'opposition et c'était des
sujets connus un des sujets habituels de
la droite la sécurité le pouvoir d'achat
l'immigration et là on a vu quelques
divisions comment c'est arrivé avec eric
ciotti ne ramenons notamment qui a été
le premier à dire qu'il était prêt à
voter eric zemmour au second tour s'il
fallait le faire pour les autres il ya
encore une ligne rouge mais on voit bien
qu'ils sont gênés par rapport au
programme d' emmanuel macron par rapport
à sa politique y compris sanitaires
xavier bertrand comme valérie pécresse
se veulent aller encore plus loin à
l'encontre des non vaccinés continuer la
politique du pass sanitaires sur
l'immigration tous sont à peu près
d'accord mais là encore emmanuel macron
tire le tapis sur la valeur travail lors
de son discours la semaine dernière il a
martelé plus d'une dizaine de fois le
mot travail et c'est long deux volets
aussi cette valeur totem de la droite
pour être le candidat finalement de la
droite même si il est plutôt du côté de
la droite centriste emmanuel macron on
voit bien que là c'est difficile de se
positionner pour les républicains avec
en plus eric zemmour qui emmène tout le
monde à sa traîne vers un discours plus
radicalisés plus dur sur avec ce thème
du grand remplacement qui n'est pas
contestée par de nombreux candidats de
la droite et donc on a vu des débats
finalement
assez peu agitée on a l'impression que
tout le monde est en mode croisière
personne n'a envie finalement de sortir
la petite phrase de trop
il ya l'épisode montebourg 1 qui a
montré que finalement l'outrance une
fois qu'on a déclaré candidat c'est
plutôt se tirer une balle dans le pied
donc c'est des débats extrêmement police
et des débats qui reste dans les clous
qui vont permettre à chacun de montrer
quelques tendances quelques nuances mais
qui sont loin là encore de faire sortir
une tête du lot merci alexis pour l'invs
avoir été avec nous